is it possible
that like basically the entirety of
earth will be like a computing surface
like this table will be doing computing
this hedgehog will be doing computing
like everything
really inefficient dumb computing would
be fiction books they call it
computronium
computing we turn everything into
computing well most of the elements
aren't very good for anything
like you're not going to make a computer
out of iron like you know silicon and
and carbon have like nice structures
you know we'll we'll see what you can do
with the rest of it
i just people talk about well maybe we
can turn the sun into computer but it's
it's hydrogen and a little bit of helium
so what i mean is more like actually
just
adding computers to everything oh okay
so you're just con
converting all the mass of the universe
into a computer no no
so not using to be ironic from the
simulation point of view is like
the simulator build mass to simulate
like
yeah i mean yeah so i mean ultimately
this is all heading towards the
simulation yeah well
i i think i might have told you the
story at tesla they were deciding
so they want to measure the current
coming out of the battery and they
decide between putting the resistor in
there
and putting a computer with a sensor in
there
and the computer was faster than the
computer i i worked on in 1982.
and we chose the computer because it was
cheaper than the resistor
so so sure this hedgehog you know it
costs 13
and we can put a you know an ai that's
the smartest you in there for five bucks
it'll have one
you know so computers will be you know
ap everywhere
i was hoping it wouldn't be smarter than
me because well everything's gonna be
smarter than you
but you were saying it's inefficient i
thought it was better to have a lot of
double
well well moore's law will slowly
compact that stuff so even the dump
things will be smarter than us
the dump things are going to be smart or
they're going to be smart enough to talk
to something that's really smart
you know it's like well just remember
like
a big computer chip yeah you know it's
like an inch by an inch
and you know 40 microns thick
it doesn't take very much very many
atoms to make a high power computer
yeah and 10 000 of them can fit in the
shoe box
but you know you have the the cooling
and power problems but you know
people are working on that but they
still can't write
uh compelling poetry or music or uh
understand what love is or have a fear
of mortality so
so we're still winning neither can most
of humanity so
well they can write books about it
you